it's been
2190 days Rihanna
weight is finally over
Queen Riri has arrived don't act like
you forgot we're excited to do the Super
Bowl taking on the biggest stage of her
life Riri is just days away from her
highly anticipated return it's just like
Super Bowl Super Bowl Super Bowl so and
we're like Rihanna Rihanna
[Applause]
and the hardest part for Riri the set
list was the biggest challenge that was
the hardest hardest part was your trial
and error you know as you started
rehearsals were you running through
setlists and real tweaking realizing
this didn't work in this moment oh yeah
oh my God they're they're probably about
39 versions of the set list right now
wow listen we'd take every single one
shine bright like a diamond but when it
comes to Rihanna's big moment she knew
the timing was right now it feels like
it could have only been now yeah and
even opens up about her beautiful baby
boy when you become a mom there's
something that just happens when you
feel like you could take on the world
you can do anything and the Super Bowl
is one of the biggest stages in the
world as scary as that was because I
haven't been on stage in seven years
there's something exhilarating about the
challenge of it all
and it's important
for for me to do this this year it's
important for representation it's
important for
my son to see that uh it's safe to say
people around the world are excited for
Rihanna's have time performance now even
the Philadelphia Eagles had some fun
answering which one was their favorite
Riri song
you can stand under my umbrella
[Music]
in fact Kansas City quarterback Patrick
Mahomes is even gushing Tiana came out
and said that you are the greatest
quarterback ever I'm psych she didn't
she did
there's still time Patrick
the game for everyone we are ready I
could have never guessed that I would
have made it here so it's a celebration
of that
[Music]